[Applause]  I'm kelcie this is my friend Annie today  we are trying another Instagram famous  food we're at trade in Irvine California  and we're going to be tried content  delicacies famous Mac Daddy burger it  has macaroni and cheeses the bun  [Music]  our yogurt it's so nice and salty it's  so juicy the cheese is really soft and  creamy but the crunch it's incredible  that's something you don't get in a  burger normally a lot of flavor going on  the breading reminds me a little bit of  tempura there's cheese in every crevice  of this or cheese in the meat there's  cheese in the mac and cheese this mac  daddy is the mack daddy of burgers  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh yes